The solution to this problem is to
construct what's called a Spanning Tree, which is
a loop-free typology that covers every node in
the graph. The set of edges, shown in
blue, constitutes what's known as a Spanning
Tree. The collection of edges in the blue
typology covers every node in the underlying physical
typology. And yet, there are no loops in
the blue topology. Now, instead of flooding a
frame, a switch in this topology would simply forward
packets along the spanning tree. So for example,
this switch would only send a frame along the
port corresponding to the blue edge. And would
not forward the frame out any edges that were
not part of the spanning tree. Other switches
that receive the frame, would flood in the same
fashion, along all edges that were part of the
spanning tree. While omitting edges that were not members of
the spanning tree. Let's take a look at how
to construct the spanning tree. First the collection of switches
must elect a root, since every tree must have
a root. Typically this is the switch with the smallest
ID. In this case, the switch at the top
of the topology is the root. Then each switch must
decide which of its links to include in the
spanning tree. And it excludes any link if that link
is determined to be not on the shortest path
to the root. For example, let's consider the switch in
the lower right. It has three lengths, this length
takes it on a path that's three hops from the
root. This length takes it on a path that's two
hops to the root, and this length takes it on
a path, that's one hop to the root. Any link
that's not on a shortest path to the route is excluded
and any link that's on a shortest path on a route
is included. Simarly here, this edge is on a path that's
one hop away from the route and this edge is
on a path that's two hops away. So this node will
include this link from the spanning tree. Now, each switch repeats
this process to exclude links from the underlying topology. And ultimately,
this yields a [UNKNOWN] topology that looks like the
blue Graph. And of course there is an issue which
is how do we determine the root in the
first place? Well initially, every node think it's the root.
And the switches run an election process to determine
which switch has the smallest ID. And if they learn
of a switch with a smaller ID, they update their
view of the root, and they compute the distance to
the new root. Whenever a switch updates its view of the root,
it also determines how far it is from that root. So that when
other neighboring nodes receive those updates. They can determine their distance
to the new root simply by adding one to any message that they receive.